the time being
1:20 let's open the um subcommittee work
session on House Bill 194 FN and we'll
open with a
discussion would you like to be
recognized representative rung yes thank
you thank you madam chair
I think the intent of the original bill
and the intent of the amendment is to
ensure that the state department of
historical
resources um keeps a current list at
least every 10 years a list of all items
in the state monuments physical
acknowledgments of that are of
historical relevance that they they
compile this inventory and they make it
available to education groups whatever
and they can easily do that through the
through a
website so I think that's the intent I
think we all agree that that should be
the responsibility of division of
historical resources is to keep a list
of our historical resources and make
sure they're
accessible I think from uh the
conversations we had previously in this
committee H is that there was some
question about the implementation of
that like what historical things are we
specific specifically talking about and
I think we also were disadvantaged
because we couldn't get
firsthand um testimony or comments from
the director of the division of
historical resources to ensure that it
wasn't going to be coming at an
additional cost to the state that it was
something that he could easily absorb
within his
Department um that he had the staff to
be able to do it so um to me I I I I
don't really think there's anybody here
that disagrees with the intent I think
where we're starting from is just on
those specifics am I
correct that's my interpretation of
where we're at right now how about
everybody
else that's what I think me and Andy had
talked about before just a scope how far
down are we going is it going to be a
grave site which we you know MEC and all
our things we have you know a specific
gravite or is it just the entire
Cemetery or our graveyard or is it um
every house that we have a plaque on
those are all histo historical things
and a lot of the even Historical Society
in March is still trying to get some of
those
together oh Madam chair is that okay
okay um absolutely actually
representative Hy when I was waiting for
this hearing to begin I was doing a
search of the rsas and I search under
monuments and monuments except for a
specific Monument that's used to
designate a
boundary um all other references to
monuments are separate from grave or
headstones gravestones or headstones so
I don't think we have to be worried that
by including historical monuments that
that's including headstones unless a
headstone is deemed to be a historical
artifact so maybe it would be the
headstone of a historic hisorical figure
would be included but just by calling it
a monument does not in fact the the
current statues actually isolate that
word from gravestones so what I see
doing and I'm not I I I I'd like to get
other people's insight into the
amendment but what I see is the marac
historical society for example they
collect they have a list or you know
they know what the historical markers
buildings groups of people whatever are
in their town and so that every 10 years
they would have to make sure that an
updated not even them the the division
of historical resources would have to
reach out to historical societies and
say hey give me your latest list of
historical items so that we can update
our list on our website um are we
capturing all of the historical items no
I'm sure not we're that's why we have
historical societies to always look and
an examine and and determine what is
historical in nature this is to me is
just a housekeeping bill to make sure
that all historical items in the state
get funneled up to the state division
who has that responsibility and that
they make sure that that list is
accessible representative Healey yeah so
that's what I brought up last time
historical commissions are formed by
lsrs
societies are volunteers so we got to
make this volunteers for them uh it
cannot be a mandatory thing for them
because they don't do they don't do like
the historical commissions do um my
hometown New Bedford Massachusetts i l
searched they have 273 in one
town I don't know how far you want to go
down that's what I that's what I think
Andy was talking about too you know we
from like I said historical houses I
okay graveyards leave it out just a
graveyard itself and you know Matthew
thon's grave would be one and nowed but
that's why I say you know we have a lot
of these all over the state and we could
catalog these I have no problem with
that um but I if you want to get below
that I just want to know how far we're
going
down yeah I I don't I think that I agree
with you that a lot of these private
organizations like the May Ma histor
iCal
Society um they wouldn't be compelled or
there would be no mandate on them to
share what their inventory with the
state but they would be invited to share
that with the state I just think this is
really a perun amendment that just the
probably the most important thing it
does is it um directs the division of
historical resources to ensure that they
have an inventory or they keep at least
a current inventory of every 10 years of
things that are are of historical
importance to the state of New Hampshire
I believe they're the ones that Define
that they can reach out to people to
keep that list current maybe there are
maram Historical Society can reach out
to them and say hey we we've just
designated this home as a historical
site um you know please add that to your
list next time it's updated but that the
division of historical resources they
would then be compelled to ensure that
that inventory is publicly accessible
and I think I don't want to speak for
representative German but I think that
was probably his biggest interest is we
need to make sure we make history
accessible to the
public representative
Rulo I
mean every I agree with everything about
you know
history is my thing
well there is so much of
it that this is everything is
historical and we we need to be able to
have a we be able need to be able to
draw boundaries on the extent of what
we're talking about and
without Mr Wilson be here we really
can't do that with it to to any any
degree of specificity
so I would really suggest that we look
at changing this bill to a
committee to be a you know I don't like
it I know the speaker don't want like it
and uh but the it's our only way of
really Sal
salvaging this this bill at the moment
is because then if you have people who
will be able to meet
to together and they would be have to
have to be
Representatives uh over the
uh uh the rest of the year to be able to
sit and work out what a bill would
really look like and with all the
specificity of of doing doing uh that
necessary uh I right now still wonder
about saying his uh will Mr
Wilson's statements that oh I don't
don't need any more money I
got we can we can do this without any
additional money well I think Finance
might want us be interested in just that
comment alone that you've got what are
you doing now
that do you have that you have extra
time to be able to do something else
something that could be very sign
ific that has to be worked out uh you
know is and what is the scope I if all
you're talking about is an Excel
spreadsheet uh that's one thing but is
how good is that for a uh uh for anyone
trying to dig into the uh to be use that
as a tool to uh to to dig into the uh
into a historical
uh in in a historical search
uh I just don't I'm not certain where we
can I don't think we can get there from
here with what we have so I would
suggest a uh a Comm a committee not a
commission commiss committee ends at the
end of this it will end at the end of
the
session representative Rong
um with all due respect to my my
colleague from Hudson I actually think
we should recommend interm study or itl
for this bill and I say it with complete
respect for representative ger but Mr
Wilson isn't here and he is a a real
subject matter expert and a real
stakeholder that we needed his input um
I don't even know if he would show up
for a study committee um and so I I just
be I I just think we have to let this
bill die um I mean if there is interest
in interm study some people can work
over it on the summer and recommend a
bill in you know late
2024 but um we have so many unanswered
questions that he's the only one that
can
answer um representative Harvey bolia
and then representative
Ryan thank you represent presentive Rong
for I totally agree um I don't think
we're going to get anywhere with um a
study committee and I don't see anything
really wrong with the bill it's just
um that I just need to have Mr Wilson
here and just what what's the impetus or
what's the
problem uh why can't he do it on his own
anyway but
um yeah I I agree thanks for bringing
that
up
you know I I don't know if he would be
interested but it may be a good idea
just to ask the speaker to send Mr
Wilson a letter asking him if he can do
this without
legislation um and maybe you know a
letter from the speaker might say that
we really want to avoid any legislative
remedy we feel that this Falls within
the purview of your Division and um
could you please tell us if this is
something you can do and if so would it
come at an additional cost and maybe
that way we could get get a response
from him um and that might help Drive
legislation that might happen in the
fall or
next
representative
Rula would you mind weighing
in thank you okay well it's being
relative to having the
speaker uh I think
uh my uh speaker has a lot more things
to worry about right at the moment than
this this issue if anything it would
come from the
committee I mean you know I obviously
I'm the chair right at the moment maybe
I'll resign by four at the end of the
day but
uh you know it that we could do that but
even then though it
uh uh it doesn't it that really doesn't
to talk to make a decision specifically
as to
the dis disposition of this
bill having a committee
is is a is a disposition inorm study is
a
disposition uh well it it there but we
have to we have to get to that first
what do what would and then we could as
part of that we could then uh
discuss what the ramifications
afterward
now my understanding is that one of the
approaches for this could be that we
would um model alongside of the marker
program that we already have there's um
a list that you can
download There's a form that you can
fill out if you want a revision of a
historical marker
or you have a problem with what it says
and you think it should be removed I
mean there's a lot of things about the
marker thing that probably wouldn't
transfer over so if you wanted to have
like we wouldn't be asking communities
to take down
something when we're talking about
monuments and listing
them
um the issue we have right now that I
see is we have have a bill that we know
is flawed because it's
directing um the wrong Department to
handle this okay it's directing the
division of archives and Records to do
this so that's why this amendment came
forward but if we recommend the original
Bill be amended with this we already
know there's flaws with that because we
want more specificity we want to get
feedback from the uh the direct dtor of
the division of historical resources so
because if we were just if this
amendment was the
bill I think we have more options but we
have to pass this amendment before we
can really do anything so I'm of the
mind that um we recommend interim study
a group of us can work together over the
summer to craft language of a bill
that essentially would be this amendment
with addressing some of the issues that
have come up in committee or that the
interim study group comes up with so
that when the next term begins we have a
much more a propriate bill that
addresses
concerns because see because the thing
is we're not really debating the bill
we're debating an amendment that hasn't
been accepted
yet a inter study is about the only
thing we can do um and then hope for the
best that that interm study group
recommends a a more solid bill in the
next
term representative
Ryan my understanding is the markers are
not monuments that's a they're totally
we're talking um apples and oranges here
so um that's a whole different area that
we're talking about right now
yes that's right and it's a different it
is what they have right now is only for
the markers it's not for anything else
and as far as just plugging into it we
wouldn't couldn't just plug into it but
we would hope I mean we would have heard
today how this could have played out
should he have been here I think a
motion of interim study is something to
consider but it's also something to like
discuss as a
caucus
what
I
sorry Brian for clarification could it
would an interm study um group be able
to go ask the people who are in charge
of this task if that was in their scope
and sequence yes absolutely and I'm
pretty sure we could get mileage for
going up there and finding out exactly
what they do and seeing how they do
it representative Ren Zula uh just uh by
looking at the original Bill the
original Bill call
says including physical markers of a
historical
event
so
markers our part are actually part of it
the original
Bill oh
yeah yeah I mean the and M M Mr
Wilson's uh M Mr Wilson's uh division
actually controls those markers and
issues them and uh does all of the you
know the work around them so there is a
list of that because that's right in his
right in his middle of his his
ballpark so it's the other stuff that
questions but uh I was um in my phone I
wasn't on Facebook I was actually
looking for the email that Ben Wilson
had sent a while back that had some of
his thoughts in it and honestly I can't
seem to track that down the the first
hearing was that in the beginning of
February somebody have those emails I
representative rang is saying that she
has that email
perhaps representative
Donnelly thank you um it would also be
very interesting to hear from the
historical societies to get their
feedback as to what they think and how
much energy that this would take so I I
personally would think that would be
helpful with the study is to hear from
uh the volunteer organizations and what
they think uh the burden of this would
be on them and and and what's the
process that they would have to follow
to um
comply I think that's really important
the impact for them they would have a
chance to come forward and shape the
bill if it has you know that shaping is
needed representative
rang I have the email U Madam CH I'll
read it it started with an email I sent
to Mr Wilson I said Ben could you
confirm if this bill HB
from archives and Records management to
division of historical resources thanks
in advance his reply was um in
consultation with the bill sponsor we
decided there would be no fiscal impact
to the division of historical resources
and therefore no need for a fiscal note
the DHR division of historical resources
is structurally organized to help
develop and maintain this kind of
educational tool within our community
outreach program thanks for the question
Ben
I think that's really helpful actually
because it sounds like he we can do this
but we need to know
how so we would like him to be more
specific um do you have thoughts on what
representative Donnell suggested I mean
in terms of historical societies and
including other people
um well my thought is that we have a
division of historical resources they
can Define what constitutes historical
so I don't think it's up to us to Define
it or to say this Monument is historical
or this isn't that's their job to do
they're the
professionals let them Define what's
historical um let them Reach Out I mean
there may be a historical society that
doesn't want anything to do with the
state division of historical resources
but leave it up to this department to
gather the historical resources identify
them in the state to the best of their
ability and
then you know catalog them put them on
the
website I really don't think this is
rocket science but I am troubled that Mr
Wilson isn't here to confirm this and
that we're relying on an email that was
sent on January
31st um
and you know I mean I think this is a
brilliant idea on the part of
Representative J's part it's a way we
can really support education in the
state at no cost it's using the
resources that we already have available
um but this is what happens when good
ideas enter the Sausage Factory of
legislation these kind of things you
know clog up the mechanism and we have
questions here everybody has very valid
questions but we don't have the person
here to answer them and so I'm really
kind of uncomfortable moving
forward um on a really good idea when
the person who's going to be responsible
for that
idea hasn't hasn't been here and so I
think that's why I was recommending
interim study because we're going to get
in the weeds of this of this amendment
and and it's not it really shouldn't be
up to us it should be up to them to be
in the weeds of this defining I mean so
I don't know that that's just my I I
think the cleanest and safest way to
proceed is just interim study unless by
some luck Mr Wilson walks in that door
we can address those issues either with
this amendment maybe we'd have to have
another amendment and then it would be
you know clean but right now I don't I
don't see where we're there
there with the executive hearing on
November 1st do you think there's any
time between now and
then possibly I mean
um we
could you know the difficult the thing
I'm grappling with and maybe it's just a
personal thing is we understood from Mr
Wilson that he couldn't come last week
and so we had it on the agenda for today
he said he was available
today and and he's not here
so yeah do we want to have another
meeting and and hope he can show up um
but I don't see how we can do anything
without him um and and anything and I'm
afraid of us doing anything without him
um he's going to be the one to dot the
eyes and cross the
teas so I I I don't know I guess it it
up to it's up to you madam chair
chairman Rulo to decide if we want to
extend the
subcommittee um and and try another day
where he can be be here to answer the
questions um I do know there were I I'm
not sure this amendment as is will fly
with the I think we need to clarify and
address some of the concerns we've had
especially with other when we mention
other um historical
groups I don't know but that's that just
uh I don't know if anybody else has any
ideas or if they think we can move
forward without Mr Wilson and and fix
this I'm not really I don't want to meet
again and possibly have them not show
up um I mean I love the history bit and
I love the promotion of history that
that the this behind this bill I mean
you can go right on to New Hampshire
.gv into the marker site and it pulls
up view the New Hampshire historical
Highway marker Map There's a list of
markers by towns there's a list of
markers by marker
number um there's a marker Quest form I
know they're thinking of more markers
than this but uh I don't think there's
any dire need to get it done like ASAP
because we do have this reference that's
very well organized already um under
historical resources
so I'm not in any big rush
thanks representative ger what are your
thoughts about um carrying the bill
forward in the terms of a
study thank you very much and I
appreciate all the work that you all
have have put into this and um I mean I
think in the end what I think would
happen is a study would result
effectively in this um and and I say
that because I wrote this working with
Mr Wilson and the frustration of course
is that he he isn't here so the language
that's here uh first of all I I have to
say again
that in in all fairness with my friends
and colleagues I'm a little frustrated
with the expressions of concern about
this being open-ended it's simply not it
refers specifically to public monuments
that are
maintained at public expense that is a
finite List It exists in every Community
because they already do it it it
involves no further Gathering of
information it is not a nebulous
category it is an existing defined
Universe of
objects uh so um and again that was
written in consultation with with Mr
Wilson
um some of the other language issues
again in terms of flexibility I don't
the bill does not require the department
to work with any particular entity in
any municipality so whether that's a
historical sitey again that was um and I
understand we don't have Mr Wilson here
but that was in you know working with
him because they have relationships with
communities so I wasn't going to direct
them that specifically they had to work
with a historical society or they had to
work with a particular Department in
certain
municipalities uh they have those
resources um and we have unfortunately
only an email at this point uh but to
indicate that there is no Financial cost
so I'm also as I think you probably
would be in my case a little frustrated
at the concern about the cost when the
department has said that this fits
within what they already do I'm not
really sure what the point of asking a
department is uh for a fiscal note if
then the response is going to be well we
don't believe you when you say that
there is no fiscal note so
um and and I and I I apologize for for
being blunt but we're all colleagues and
those are just my uh reactions I don't
really think a study committee is going
to result in anything other than than
what we have here I think what we have
is um unfortunately that the director
couldn't come to confirm what as it said
this language was written specifically
so that it would not have a fysical
impact so that it would be done in a way
that fits within work that the
department already does and so that's of
course a source of my frustration and
there is no as we mentioned last time
there is no enforcement right in the end
this is voluntary there you know the
department isn't going to chase anybody
down they're not going to expend extra
resources to do that uh so it is
ultimately voluntary the reason why it
was uh I wrote it as as a bill that
would go into statute as opposed to
Simply uh seeing if the department could
could do this
you know on its own was the maintaining
it every 10 years right that that would
be the statutory implication here U so
that is and I am entirely uh in you know
I'd love to work with the Department to
help them do uh more in this area so to
me it's not that the activity itself per
se has to be in statute but it's the
making sure that it's done every 10
years uh is the part that's important to
me so again I want to thank you all for
the time and effort that you put into it
I share your frustration that
unfortunately we haven't been able to he
hear directly from the
director representative Ryan can we
approve the
amendment that seems to clarify no what
the questions that we had from the
original
Bill Mr chair do you care to weigh in on
that procedural
question right but the amendment it's
the amendment itself would off have to
be approved by the full committee uh but
uh but there's I think the amendment
itself uh clears up an original problem
that was that was noted at the very
beginning but uh whether an amendment is
there or not there's still problems and
that's that's really I think what we
were hearing for those additional
information that we needed from Mr
Wilson please would it be feasible and I
understand if the answer is no uh with
the session that you have coming up
right on November 1st if you were to and
I I absolutely get you know we we don't
want to do anything which depends on the
director being here um because we've
already gone down that road twice uh but
if he were to confirm to the committee
in
writing again what he had said earlier
in the year I understand months have
gone by things may well have changed but
if he were able to confirm that as
amended which again is based on the
conversations I had with him that this
is something that they can do with the
resources that they
have is it possible then to have the
committee on November first vote to
approve the amendment and then have a
vote over whether or not to approve the
amended Bill if and again that would be
if uh the director responds with a
confirmation that there are no
additional resources
required representative run I think
that's a very good idea because we've
never received any testimony from Mr
Wilson um all we have is this email so I
think why not why not just ask him if he
would write a letter of testimony to
submit to the committee um when we have
our executive session um about this
amendment if if he's in favor of it if
he's not in favor of it and if
he uh can make a statement regarding any
fiscal impact and then we're going to be
an executive session anyway we can then
vote to uh approve the amendment and
then vote for the bill as amended
because I really think the sticking
point at least with me is we don't have
anything from directly from him um and
when you look at all the bills that come
through our committee we always have at
least written testimony if not also oral
testimony from the Department that's
impacted so I think if we can get that
testimony from him at least written for
the executive committee um I would be
fine with that but without that
Department's statement
I have a really hard time approving any
Bill representative Ryan and then
representative Healey would that excuse
me thank you would that satisfy um
representative R's concerns about the
original
Bill
no the only thing I was going to say he
if he could also just include what he's
going to win include in this how far
down he's going to go like you said so
he would Define the scope is that what
you mean representative Healey Define
scope
yep did you put down what you know what
was the need for the
bill exactly um if there was a reason
why he can't do it already I think you
said that
before representative run uh chairman
Rulo at that executive committee um the
ex excutive session would he be able to
be called on by you to answer any
questions for
clarification really thinking about
this technically
yes but it's almost but I'm at the point
now where having gone twice
to this
position I mean I'm not I I feel that
I'm maybe getting to the point
that uh we we can only make so many
allowances how many how much more allow
how many more allowances can we
have we can we have a situation where
nobody bothers to
testify but they'll just send in a
letter and and then when we get when the
letter is is when there's issues well
well then they come up and
testify that such a bad
precedent so I have to think about
that Mr chairman I totally agree with
you on that but I'm also
weighing weighing the advantages of
getting this addressed and taken care of
because it is a really good idea and I
know our our
teachers all throughout the state would
really appreciate having this resource
and knowing that at least every 10 years
it's
updated so I think the benefit of having
this pass
outweighs the sense
of discomfort there's a feeling I have
between discomfort and disrespect about
not being able to have this kind of
testimony so I agree with you but I but
when you are thinking about it just
think about the benefit this will
provide um students in our
state well I think about
everybody who comes to
testify to this committee and other
committees that you know we have a
process
and at some
point pushing the envelope the envelope
breaks and I think that you have to step
back and say well do we want to set a
precedent that we can that we can
allow
uh The Lax
Behavior to
uh that there has to be some kind
of push back against it so I'm going to
have to have a long talk thinking about
that representative Donnell thank you I
agree with representative Rulo if you
open this the doorways to uh you know
the
uh not showing sending letters it does
open the doorway for others because it
does set a president so it's uh we all
took our time to be here today so it
would have been quite nice to see him
thank you
yes it would have I agree
[Music]
um you know I I really would have a hard
time iing this
bill but to move to getting me on that I
mean the other options are
studies which may not bring us
to getting the information from the
expert that we you know the person that
in the department that this really
affects so I
I'm kind of at an impass with it I don't
want to see it go itl but I know that if
we did an interim study that the fact
that we would study it would really be
the only procedural difference between
an itl and an inome
study
well I'm going to be my optimistic
self and I'm going to expect that at our
executive session we have a very nice
letter from Mr Wilson outlining the
impact this amendment would have on his
Department um the benefits if there are
any costs or disadvantages to it but we
really get an official Department
statement and our committee has made a
very bright people I think we could read
that and understand if we should move
ahead to accept the amendment and then
pass the bill as amended so I I think
this is something that let's let's um
bring it to the executive session I
think as far as the subcommittee
goes um we are
recommending I think do we have to take
a vote on some action today
no so I think we just let's leave it up
to the full committee and if and if we
have a letter and if it's acceptable to
the committee and the committee decides
we're going to accept the amendment and
pass the bill as amended then we're good
to go but if we we don't have
satisfaction with that letter that the
the division is in support of this then
um then at that
time I would I would recommend itl
and wait for it to come back the
following
term it would be the same procedurally
and then we wouldn't be obligating the
sponsor and all of us to continue to
work on something just simply because we
don't have the information and we we're
not getting it right
away um and I understand um I want to
just address what representative branula
was saying yes we would not want people
to send in letters and not come in and
testify but we should take what we have
right now deal with the work that's
before us and vote objectively on the
information and not you know in do
anything
punitive which would be to you know to
me no there's no rush on this but kids
grow up and they go away and this is a
family activity at a time when you know
there's just so many things that can be
done with this Monument list that I
think would be really powerful that
shouldn't have to wait if we can do
something less last minute and just see
what the rest of the committee said I
wouldn't have a problem with this 10 to
10 and having to work it out on the
floor either so and I just say that
because we're procedurally up against
the wall we want the bill but we can't
get
there go ahead represent yeah I just I
just want to make one statement clear I
really really support this but I think
as the committee any any committee it's
really important for us to understand
directly from the Department uh any
division um what their responses to
actions we take
legislatively um I don't think I could
ever consider a bill that impacts let's
say Dees without Dees weighing in on it
sometimes we override there what what
the comments they make if if they are
making a recommendation it doesn't we're
not rubber stamping what they have but I
just think what the the a bet the worst
president I see here is passing a bill
that impacts a division without getting
input from that division on that impact
and that goes across the board for any
standing
committee go ahead represent go ahead
representative hey and I would put out
one more um request that you show up on
the 1 if he can just in case we do have
any questions again so you know you
though he puts this letter out there may
be questions that come out of that
letter so I would say if he can make it
on the first put that uh invitation out
to
him anyone else have thoughts about
that I do think that we should invite
him to the first we have to exec the
bill either way if he's here and we want
to ask questions of him then that would
be an
opportunity
um but I think we've gone as far as we
can without you know that exactly what
you said the agency needs to weigh in we
need them to weigh
in motion to adjourn do we have a second
second
seconded